There is something so captivating about ice.
It can be beautiful, a shimmering cast of
frost over a meadow or twinkling icicles on
a cottage roof.
It can also be deadly: A slick of slippery
glass on a dark road, or that same icicle
from before, knocked loose and careening toward
your head like a falling dagger.
It can be a sleet storm or a mighty glacier
with secrets buried beneath its core.
In a remote part of Alaska, the SCP Foundation
discovered a particularly unusual kind of
ice, with a vivid red hue and some incredibly
deadly potential.
The Foundation investigated reports in a remote
area on the Alaskan coastline after a tribe
of local natives came across the mangled bodies
of shipwrecked hunters in the area, encased
in a block of strange red ice.
Mobile Task Force Beta-7, also known as The
Haz-Matters, was sent in to the site to determine
what exactly had occurred and take samples
of any anomalous materials to be brought back
to the nearest Foundation research site.
Agent Bryce made the initial visual inspection
of the site and spotted three middle-aged
male bodies.
Further examination determined that one of
the bodies, referred to as Subject Zero, was
the original point of contamination for whatever
comprised the red ice and caused the men’s
deaths.
It has been posited by the investigative team
that the other men were infected when they
attempted to help Subject Zero reach their
boat.
Sadly, kindness can sometimes be a killer
like that.
While sweeping the perimeter, Agent Hewes
spotted human footprints leading to the Northeast.
A three-man team consisting of Agents Hewes,
Whitmore, and Cassidy was permitted to follow
those tracks and determine if any survivors,
or something worse, had escaped the site.
Exploration Log A009 1 allows us to determine
what happened next, and what the three agents
found.
Hewes and his team followed the footprints
to the entrance of a cave, with the tracks
appearing to lead inside.
The entrance of the cave was covered with
an almost solid sheet of ice, save for a crack
in the ice about one meter tall.
Beyond this wall, Agent Whitmore spotted the
body of a young man, frozen solid in the midst
of crawling away from something, covered in
crystals of red ice.
With him was a frozen spear gun that appeared
to have been fired just before the young man’s
death.
They could not touch the body to perform a
full investigation, but the way in which he
was gripping his chest indicated he might
have been fatally stabbed there.
As the agents moved further into the cave,
they discovered a chamber about 5 or 6 meters
in diameter, filled with red ice with a pool
in the middle.
The pool was three meters wide and of an unknown
depth.
As they pushed further, the agents came across
a polar bear.
Startled, they fired once at it, before realizing
it was already dead.
Its fur was dotted with crystals of red ice,
creeping its way across the bear’s body.
Beyond the polar bear, the agents spotted
dozens of bodies, all dead animals.
There were seals, a snow fox, and finally…a
giant spider, with a leg span of over a meter.
At first, the spider appeared to be frozen
like the other creatures, but upon further
investigation, it appeared to be made of red
ice.
Agent Cassidy recognized the spider as SCP-3023
but was told it was impossible.
When she pressed for further answers, she
was told to ignore it and continue the sweep.
Agent Whitmore checked the collection of bodies
in the chamber, looking for any humans among
them.
Meanwhile, Hewes spotted a spear sticking
out of the enormous spider, indicating a struggle
that took place before it and the young man
at the cave’s entrance froze.
Hewes was interrupted in his task as Agent
Cassidy called out from deeper in the cave,
saying: “I think I know where the spider
came from.”
When Hewes followed the sound of her voice,
he found something troubling.
An aperture, about a meter in diameter, absolutely
covered in red ice.
It looked like a tunnel, with no ice at all
past its entrance, with a dim light coming
from somewhere deep inside.
He lost sight of Agent Cassidy and realized
she must have gone inside of it.
Upon further observation, Hewes determined
that the walls and the floor of the tunnel
were wet, with a red puddle about a meter
in.
Hewes and Whitmore called to Cassidy, attempting
to lead her back out of the tunnel, but received
no response.
Hewes attempted to go in and retrieve her,
but Control forbade him from going any further.
After a conversation with Control that has
been stricken from the official file, Hewes
relented and agreed to withdraw his remaining
team and exit the site.
Hewes and Whitmore left the cave without further
incident and returned to Foundation headquarters.
In spite of a D-Class recovery team being
sent into the cave to search for her, Agent
Cassidy’s body was never found.
The cave was blocked off from the public,
in order to avoid further civilian contact
with the red ice and red water inside.
Though the origin of the red ice in Alaska
is not known for sure, this cave, and the
pool deep within it, are thought to be the
source of this particular infestation.
The official cause of death listed on record
for the bodies found in Alaska was internal
bleeding, but what really happened to them
was something much, much worse.
These men had transformed and frozen from
the inside out, their blood turning to ice
and their cells going solid one at a time.
The low ambient temperatures in the area are
thought to have slowed the freezing process
down.
You heard that right, the cold kept them from
freezing faster, as counterintuitive as it
sounds.
This prolonged their deaths and kept them
conscious up until the very end.
Even as their bodies were freezing solid,
their very cells turning against them, they
were awake and aware of it all.
These unfortunate men came into contact with
and lost their lives to a substance known
as SCP-009.
SCP-009 in its liquid form, maintained at
temperatures between -100 and 0 degrees Celsius,
resembles ordinary distilled water aside from
its bright red color.
It behaves opposite of water, reaching a frozen
solid state at higher temperatures, and vaporizing
into a steam-like gas at temperatures below
-100 degrees.
An attempt to examine SCP-009’s atomic structure
was unable to achieve conclusive results.
The substance looks as if it is made up of
normal water molecules, though obviously,
it is much more than simple water.
SCP-009 appears relatively harmless at first
glance, but its real dangerous potential lies
in its ability to contaminate water-based
solutions, transferring its properties to
them.
A contaminated liquid begins to exhibit the
same unusual behavior as SCP-009, freezing
at temperatures above 0 degrees and vaporizing
at temperatures below -100.
It has been shown to effectively contaminate
ice, steam, tea, fruit juice, seawater, and
blood, in a process taking between three minutes
and several hours.
These concerning properties raised questions
about what SCP-009, and liquids contaminated
by it, might do if they make contact with
a human body.
Several D-Class Personnel were used as test
subjects, exposed to SCP-009 in a controlled
environment and observed from a safe distance.
When first exposed to SCP-009, the test subjects
reported nothing unusual except a slight sensation
of warming on the surface of their skin.
Then, frost began to form across the surface
of the exposed area as the subject’s body
heat raised the substance’s temperature.
This process took between a minute and a few
hours, during which ice crystals began to
form along the top layer of the skin.
This stage is known as “Surface Conversion.”
In the next stage, “Deep Tissue Conversion,”
the continued increase in SCP-009’s temperature
causes a ripple effect of reactions through
the subject’s body, ice crystals forming
in the cells and throughout the blood.
The subject remained alive and conscious during
this stage.
Details about the fourth stage of the process
have been expunged from the official record,
but it is safe to say that something horrible
happened.
After several of these experiments were conducted,
testing on living D-class subjects was officially
discontinued.
There was a possibility of experimentation
on SCP-009 regarding its potential application
to cold fusion, but this was also eventually
discontinued following a disastrous accident
at an unnamed Foundation test site.
The site was completely destroyed, and pieces
of the lead Agent conducting the cold fusion
research have still not been recovered.
For now, SCP-009 is kept under strict containment
and only tested under particular, highly regulated
circumstances.
SCP-009 is kept in a sealed storage tank of
heat-resistant alloy.
It is not to be exposed to any temperatures
higher than zero degrees Celsius unless there
is official, Foundation-sanctioned testing
being done.
No water-based liquids are allowed within
30 meters of the containment area.
The storage tank is outfitted with temperature
sensors that are to be monitored at all times
in order to prevent the temperature within
from rising and is kept cold by three different
cooling units.
If the sensors or cooling units malfunction
for any reason, they must be fixed immediately
to prevent disaster.
When testing is done on SCP-009, the containment
area is kept in a vacuum and the personnel
working with it must wear protective gear.
After testing, all involved personnel must
quarantine for at least 12 hours.
Any living organisms contaminated by SCP-009
must be terminated promptly.
While the exact origins of SCP-009 are unclear,
it clearly does not follow the laws of nature
as we understand them.
A Foundation expert in Xenospatial Physics
suggested that SCP-009 may have come from
a universe with alternate laws of physics,
explaining its reversal of the ordinary conditions
for states of matter.
During an instance of SCP-507 - The reluctant
dimension hopper - shifting into an alternate
universe, an instance of SCP-009 was unexpectedly
observed that may help confirm that theory.
In the test area where SCP-507 appeared, red
snow fell for about 27 minutes.
Grass touched by this red snow began to react
and freeze over within a few minutes.
The other plant life touched by the snow turned
bright red and expanded to a larger size.
It also began to sprout bright blue tentacles
covered with red mucilage.
Upon closer examination, the mucilage turned
out to be comprised of small amounts of SCP-009.
This raised additional questions, for instance:
how are these plants able to survive constant
exposure to SCP-009?
This matter is currently under investigation,
but the prevailing theory is that this plant
is an example of plant life from SCP-009’s
native universe.
Whatever it is, and wherever it comes from,
it should not be allowed to come into contact
with earth-based organic life forms.
Well, not unless being horrifically frozen
to death by your own body feels like an appealing
experience to you.
The coastline where SCP-009 was initially
discovered, and its first victims on record
were found, was located very close to the
ocean.
Thankfully, the exact area of contamination
was dry and cold enough to keep the red ice
from spreading, but if it had been even a
few meters closer to the water it could have
spread into the North Pacific Ocean.
With contamination of that scale, it could
have very easily infected thousands of people,
perhaps spreading into other bodies of water
and triggering a global extinction event.
Because of this threat, several members of
the SCP Foundation proposed that SCP-009 be
upgraded to Keter class in order to reflect
its danger to humanity.
However, this request was denied due to the
currently effective containment measures in
place.
The red ice is unable to spread to new hosts,
infecting the water supply and turning all
living things into frozen husks.
For now.
Let’s just hope we don’t see any red snowstorms
any time soon.
Now go check out “SCP-1861 - The Crew of
the HMS Wintersheimer” and “The Horror
of Body Stealing Rain - SCP-3300” for more
SCPs that’ll make you afraid to ever get
back into the water!